the neighborhood congratulations picked
up for a second season it's a funny show
it's actually it's a cool cast and it's
a you know obviously for such a long
time in this country race has been a hot
button topic still is and this is a show
that's dealing with it and but also you
know in a way that where people can
laugh yeah you know it was it was a show
we you know this show is created by Jim
Reno's
really about gentrification this is
something that's going on all around how
you know it seem like we're being pulled
apart right now you would think that
everybody is kind of being pulled and
have to pick a side and then we started
to talk about when a neighborhood starts
to change when someone moves in and so
the show is about this this young white
family moving into this predominately
black neighborhood and you know and how
we learn to get along
you know and so but you start to see
that like you know you can know when
gentrification is coming do you know I
mean do you view yourself you think when
you drive around you're able to look at
a neighborhood to say I know this is
about to gentrify your identification is
you're happening right now oh yeah you
can look at it you can just tell like
soon soon as there's not a check cashing
place there and use it you go like where
did that Starbucks come from that was
always gives it away it's just a dead
giveaway so as you go to you like oh it
start to happen starting to happen
anytime you see a hybrid dog you know it
like okay wait a minute is that what
does it amount be yeah my postal dude
yeah you see it Labradoodle with
Starbucks opposed like downward dog but
you see a downward dog with a dog in
yoga pants it starts to change yeah
people don't bicycles late at night you
know you're like okay this is like it's
starting to be a whole new thing around
here
it takes you at least you know 40
minutes to find a Popeye's Chicken you
like
[Laughter]